you do gang up on me and this time is no
different because kelly clarkson
just caught blake shelton in a lie you
know what's interesting
is um nope you left your jacket here in
the green room
yeah you actually neglected
to even throw it away after leaving the
building
you still have it oh yeah no we've had
your jacket here we're saving it for you
oh there it is i've been looking for
this here's what happened on monday
shelton and fellow voice judges nick
jonas and john legend
visited the kelly clarkson show where
the host gave john
a team kelly jacket for appearing on her
show four times
you get your official everything
yes put this on and blake was also
honored with the same jacket back in
september
do you wear your jacket all the time oh
my god yeah all the time
i feed the chickens in it i feed the
chickens
yeah but not so fast kelly revealed that
the jacket
never left the building oh yeah no we've
had your jacket here we're saving it for
you
oh there it is i've been looking for
this yeah the chickens will miss you
no totally thank you very much brand new
blake
it looks brand new just to prove that
that idea it says season 19 on it yeah
here's the thing you know when you don't
like a gift you like
wait till you leave the building i
always throw it away
but of course in true blake fashion he
got out of that one
real quick and asked for a drink i do
remember that you let us drink last time
we were on this show
would you like a drink yes i'd like you
to keep my gifts so maybe you'll get a
drink when you keep my gift
the voice is celebrating its 10th
anniversary on the air
this year and the stars are aligning
literally for the season
20 finale in addition to the current
coaches the star-studded two-night
finale event will feature performances
from a host of musical superstars
including a few familiar faces former
coach adam levine will make his return
to the voice stage as his band maroon 5
performs their latest single beautiful
mistake
featuring meghan the stallion
one stefani whose contestant carter
rubin won season 19 of the show
will also be back to hand off the crown
as she and sweetie perform their hit
single slow class
other star power hitting the voice stage
justin bieber
snoop dogg kelsey ballerini thomas rhett
and ben platt
as for how the coaches will celebrate
well here's what kelly and john told e.t
earlier this month
we do a dinner on the last night of
lives it's the opposite of a party
though is so chill we just have dinner
we have a glass of wine and we're
grown-ups yeah
not lots because i have to work at like
8 a.m the next day for my other show
she's always working the next day i know
and does blake bring his smithworks
vodka you know usually
i don't know he'll have some wine with
[Music]
us
you